how to report a Willl coxen test
according to APA style first of all what
is a Willl coxen test a wilcoxen test
tests whether there is a pair difference
between two paired samples and The Wil
coxen test is the nonparametric
counterpart to the T test for peered
samples but how to report a wil coxen
test reporting a wil coxen test
according to APA style requires
presenting key statistics in a clear
concise manner here's a general
guideline on how to report the results
in five steps finally I'll show you how
to automatically create the
interpretation for your data number one
descriptive statistics Begin by
providing descriptive statistics for the
two related samples you're comparing
medians are typically used for
non-parametric data example exle the
median score before the intervention was
MD equal to 22 and after the
intervention it was MD equal to 28
number two test statistic stat the value
of the wilcoxen test which is usually
denoted as W or T and the P value
example a will Cox signed rank test
indicated that scores were significantly
different before and after the inter
mention W = to
132.5 P = to
0.02 W is the calculated W value P equal
to 0.02 is the P value adjust this
according to your results for example P
= to
0.045 P = to
0.25 and so on and so forth number three
effect size it's recommended to include
and effect size such as R this provides
the reader with an understanding of the
magnitude of the difference the effect
size R for the wi coxen test can be
calculated as r equal to Z ided by the
root of n where n is the number of
paired observations example the effect
size was moderate r equal to
0.40 for the interpretation of of the
effect size you can use this table
number four interpretation conclude with
a clear plain language interpretation of
the results example does the
intervention have a statistically
significant effect on the scores whether
the difference is significant or not
depends on whether the calculated P
value is smaller or larger than a
specified significance level the
significance level is usually 5% if the
P value is less than
0.05 there is a significant difference
otherwise not number five graphs and
tables while not always necessary visual
aids such as box plots showing the
distributions of scores before and after
the intervention can be helpful ensure
that any visual aids are clearly labeled
and formatted according to apa
guidelines here's a complete example the
median score before the intervention was
MD = to 22 and after the intervention it
was MD equal to 28 a will coxon signed
rank test indicated that scores were
significantly different before and after
the intervention W equal to
132.5 P smaller than
0.05 the effect size was moderate r
equal to
0.4
thus the intervention had a
statistically significant effect on
scores of course when you calculate a
will Cox signed rank test online with
data tab the summary in words is
automatically generated for you just
copy your data into this table select
your variables click on
nonparametric and wilcoxen test and then
click on summary in
wordss Remember When writing up your
results
aim for clarity and precision ensure
that someone reading a report can easily
understand the statistical analysis
you've conducted and the implications of
the findings thanks for watching and I
hope you enjoyed the
video